okay good
morning morning thank you very much for
coming I'm going to talk about a
successful experience that we have
carried out at univers Carlos Tero
Madrid or university Charles II of
Madrid Spain you see that my name is
very similar to the name of my
University I'm running so my own
University Carlos Tero Charles thei was
a king in Spain 250 years
ago so let me first explain the setting
freshmen come to University with the in
theory necessary requirements to fully
follow the courses they have chosen but
this is just in theory in practice we
see we know that they are always
sometimes gaps they have forgotten
things they didn't fully understand
especially stem physics math chemistry
Etc so
what many spish universities have been
introducing a few years ago is what we
call zero courses courses very short
courses that take place before the real
first semester the the fall semester
starts now the problem is several years
ago the semester normally started at 20
something of September but then suddenly
everything was Advanced uh until maybe
the 7th or 8th of September so before we
had three weeks
for these zero courses to re to re
review the content but now we have only
one week and the problem is that there's
a lot of content to
review and the students are too diverse
to really feel the needs F the
gaps the fact is professors cannot teach
all the content that is necessary just
to review to prepare them for the fall
semester so what did we do
we call it the genis project because
it's another KH we took the KH Academy
platform which until September 2012 was
open
source we adapted it with our own uh
learning management system which is
Moodle and we had our professors
make uh videos alakan and exercises
alakan first in physics and then also in
chemistry and math so we just took the
platform and the content were from our
professors in Spanish and dedicated to
the needs that of of content for the uh
coming classes so for instance we have
physics one and physics 2 which take
place these are the real courses in fall
and spring semester we had this
September face-to-face teaching but this
since this wasn't enough we added to it
an online part using a can academ
platform in August
so we expanded the one week we had by
four or five weeks more but this four or
five weeks were just online with a kadic
platform let me show you a few details
uh so we started in 2012 we just had the
first pilot in physics let's call it
physics zero in 2013 we added math in
chemistry and now as we speak in August
2014 we have the third uh round of uh
this experiment I'm going to report on
the physics zero uh in 2013 we don't
have results for 2014 because it's still
running so what did we do we took the
Can Academy platform we coupled it with
the Moodle which is our learning
management system in order to have
single sign on we had the physics
professors do at the beginning of 2012
make can sty videos make quizzes from
the can uh platform
and then we had during August the
students uh see all this material do all
these
exercises together with elements like
gamification elements like badges which
we personalize we customize to the local
setting of Carlos Tero we took basically
monuments of of his time as badges to
reward the students and with a social
component which especially in 2012 was
very intense the students helped
themselves a lot and in parallel K
Academy platform has a very good
Analytics tool a very good dashboard
with lots of indicators that helped the
professors prepare the face-to-face part
so we're much better informed where were
the problems what were the students
struggling with let me show you some
screenshots this is the Moodle that then
gave rice or helped to to access the
videos and exercise es this uh then it
students didn't realize that there were
suddenly in the Can Academy platform
this is some video uh can Style video
then there were also experiments made
the important is that the students in
control they can repo repeat pause Etc
the videos then there were these
exercises parameterized exercises so
every time you call it you get a
different set of values with hints so if
if you are stuck you can uh ask for a
hint another hint Etc the importance in
this case of immediate feedback to have
the student in control of the learning
then we had these gamification Badges
and energy
points I said customized to these
Charles the thir monuments starting with
the p Al kala and going through
different monuments in Madrid and then
the social learning component was very
important a student asked I got stuck
and photographed the sheet of paper I'm
having problems is this right and
another would solve it and help him so
in which case both learned the one who
is asking and the one who is helping the
other
student uh the social component happened
in on Moodle and the videos and
exercises were on on can and then the
analytics analytics which is very rich
you could this is an actual
picture each of these uh change there of
this dots is one student you could see
that some are very fast some wait till
the end to completely videos and some
were having their own pace uh as needed
you remember this was in August
typically August is the month of
holidays of vacation Spain maybe they
were at the beach on theth mountain or
whatever and they were following this
and then we didn't remove the face Toof
face path it took place but the
professors were much better informed of
what's going on now the cany platform
has a very good learning analytics has a
lot of indicators what is happening
where the problems are for instance we
saw that there was a problem with one of
the quizzes they had to determine the
angle between two
vectors which is very easy
straightforward to to
this this exercise but we were looking
we were seeing that the students were
failing there why would they fail the
problem is that it was not well stated
since the uh exercise was parameterized
every time you got a different set of
vectors and also the zero Vector the
vector which is of zero length is a
possible vector and and then the angle
is not well defined so we saw that the
problem had to be changed we should not
allow the zero Vector in this particular
exercise and we could see it in one of
these
dashboards apart from this lowlevel
analytics provided by KH Academy we have
added additional high level analytics in
order to have additional information for
instance how is the efficiency in
learning maybe they reach the same
results but how fast they have been or
are the uh students hint abusers or hint
avoiders or uh follow do they follow the
recommendations so the number of higher
level analytics which we programmed on
top of the lowlevel analytics
provided by Can
Academy I show you here some examples
completion of videos so
81% of the videos uh started where
finished Etc you could see differences
in this efficiency in learning so the
time it it takes you to to reach the
different objectives and goals
Etc but we wanted to know a bit more we
wanted to know was it really useful was
it h did it help for the students to
learn apart from passing the exams of
this zero course uh and I will show you
three preliminary results three
different
analysis one is a satisfaction survey we
ask the students did you like it or not
second uh we compared the results of the
zero cause with previous cohorts where
we didn't have this kind of Academy
content and third we wanted to know what
is the effect on the fall semester on
the physics one course did it improve
the marks for whom did it
improve okay the the satisfaction survey
was positive over five we got four
points or so but more importantly even
we got the congratulations from the
student delegation not students uh if
things work they don't say anything they
only complain if things don't work but
you got H congratulations we want more
of that that's very good please continue
this way
secondly we compared the average marks
of the previous year from 2006 until
2012 only face tof face part and we saw
that adding this online part improved
the marks the grades so this is also
positive and a statistical relevant
difference
but more importantly we want to improve
the learning of physics
one so in order to analyze this we
divided the students into four
categories and for this we use the
University entry exam so students in
Spain when they enter or they want to
enter University they have to pass a
nation VI wide exam everybody has to
take the same so and they get some marks
it goes to 14 it's very complicated I
will not explain the details but we
divide it into these four categories you
have to get the five in order to pass to
enter University and then there are some
additional requirements Etc but so we
divided in these four categories very
good students 11 to 14 good students
medium and bad and try to analyze what
was the effect on this K academic
contents on them and we compareed the
students who passed the physics zero
course on those who didn't take it
because it was not compulsory it was
just on a voluntary basis that they
could take they had even to pay for this
physics zero C so these are the
results on the right hand
side those who did not take physics zero
on the right hand side on the left hand
side those who took it but also passed
it because you can take it and then
don't do anything at all don't look at
any video don't do any exercise and we
saw
that the very good students there was no
effect they knew the material they knew
the physics no change at
all the good students the same exactly
the same which is kind of strange but
but this is the average number but more
interestingly the medium
students there was a big Improvement and
this is where there's Improvement
possible those who are who didn't grasp
anything or everything but so it helped
them to get from here to here which is a
considerable
Improvement so in this way it was
satisfactory what happened with the bad
ones the bad one didn't even take it or
take it seriously enough so they they
they have not passed it at all and
they're still the worst ones no so the
situation
is data shows we are on the right
track good and very goods at least don't
get worse don't change they don't
improve either medium students improve a
lot so we helped a big number of
students to improve and bad students
they don't even take physics zero or
don't take it seriously the challenge is
now how to motivate bad students I think
the situation is similar to what happens
in muks who takes muks those who are
educated who have a bachelor's or
master's program maybe not those who
really need it or who could take so it's
a similar challenge no how to motiv
bad students to engage and to take this
additional content and maybe another
challenge is how can we challenge these
students even to improve
more so these are almost my 15
minutes uh it was also interesting to
inform the formation of groups for the
face Toof face part with the results of
the onl parts before we group them just
alphabetically because we make small
groups of of of 20 students and uh we
took we took good students together and
bad shes together because they have
different needs so the online part also
helped in the formation of groups for
the face to face part so we saw the
value of muks or Spock or Muk technology
in on in on campus setting for leveling
we want to met measure better and more
now we are running it for the Third time
we have having pre- test and post test
in order really to see what is the
learning in um
Effectiveness and more things we want to
do we want to create at the University
more this culture of creating online
content and setting out the necessary
support for staff facilities we which we
have started but I think we need two
more of that so I would like to finish
um by acknowledging many people have
been involved here the physics
professors some researchers the vice
director for under studies who has
helped a lot of what staff Etc so
setting up these things means setting up
a lot of things and I think we have we
can I can report fortunately a quite
positive
experience
VJ since it's being recorded do you want
to go up to the mic or the mic can come
to
you
on the dashboard that you were
showing is uh what was used to change
the treatment during the course because
a lot of the data was summitted in the
course when you're looking at the
analytics what you mean course you mean
online part or or the face to
face talking yeah was it being used to
change the instruction oftion in real
time or was it just used for data to get
these kind of result yeah no it was not
used in real time so during August I
mean there there are not even professors
there I mean there are some people
monitoring it just in case there are
catastrophes but the students were alone
there with the material and we were
getting all information and this the
professors they come back from vacation
in August and then they get this
information and it's used to inform the
face Toof face path so it's very clearly
two separated phes and there's no real
time
yeah you pass it
over yeah but but the the if you agree
the for for the recording around yeah
pass thank you so you mentioned about
gamification habits the badge those kind
of things really could motivate students
to participate I mean that we asked the
students and they really liked it
because I got this badge and then they
tweeted it to their friends I've got
this we have have you got it as well so
it really motivated and and and helped
in in the in the small to to keep them
um ahead yes and and you didn't include
this one as a like a requirement or is
it require or counted toward their grade
or I wasn't so sure about in terms of
curriculum design is it in terms of
curriculum it doesn't give any Mark it's
just for helping them get better marks
in physics one and physics 2 Etc so it's
not a requirement it's voluntary and
there's no Mark that counts towards the
the curriculum
MH again just a clarification how many
students were in your
study uh around
100 I have
the yeah over
100 I mean the students have to register
for it and they have to pay for it
around 50 or so so um so it's not
compulsory those and this were the 180
not all of them really
followed and and saw all the material so
it is a quite big distribution from
those who maybe didn't enter at all for
from th to those who did a little bit
from those who followed all the all the
videos and all the exercises so it's
it's a big big spread of actual use so
how many
video uh
uh yeah I don't have the exact response
to more than 100 in any case yes and
then it dropped off did and then it
dropped off
yeahh um in your student satisfaction
survey I noticed that the usefulness of
quizzes was lower than the lower than
vide yeah but Effectiveness was actually
higher as you showed in the last one do
you have any thoughts explanations for
for why that is yeah I I think one one
problem is that we use the kanak as is
and kanak requires to do every exercise
eight times this is very deep
uh programmed into the into the platform
so it's very difficult to change we
looked at it how to change this and this
was a bit boring for the students why do
I have to do the same thing eight times
in order to get a badge so so this is
one problem with the can academ it has
many good things but one of the things
is this necess necessity to do
everything eight times and I think this
discourage the students a little bit to
do the quizzes yeah
MH the idea is to go next year for
openex which is also important challenge
for openex to have the good
analytics tools yes I think it's really
compelling to do um a blended course
because you have personal interaction
with students and then they can maintain
that interaction with some facilities
online if you give them good networking
or social facilities can you comment on
how well you thought that worked in your
case and what you thought was the
technology that helped it work and what
gaps there might be that we need to
address well this is a very
comprehensive question yeah I
think especially if your student
population is very
diverse uh you cannot lecture it all you
you you you cannot teach everything that
would be needed for everybody to to be
satisfied so using online tools
additionally helps a lot just to level
as in this case or maybe for those
students who who want to deepen into one
particular subject to have Al additional
material so I think only face Toof face
is really too poor for for a a big
population so online tools are more and
more necessary and this is by the way
what we're going to do in the rest of
this this uh session today and I'm going
to explain in a minute no um it's
important to have good tools that give
you good information give you good
analytics give you good information what
is going on uh in this case uh I think
KH provided a very good background and
helped us a lot of course we want to
tune things so it's important that you
also have the ability to to work with
this tool and and and to change it h for
your particular context which in every
country over every different context is
it might be different um what else did
you ask
ask students have to make when they have
personal interaction in the classroom
yeah and you get to know them and you as
a professor or an instructor you connect
to them and they gather your passion for
learning this material how does that
transition online how do they remain a
person to you
online yeah I in this case you get lost
and become Anonymous maybe that's good
maybe that's bad but we blend the course
so that we had that Bond I just comment
had that Bond we didn't in this case um
I mean we had the face tof face face s
before this didn't change at all we just
added this additional online so this
connection with the professor was there
as it was before we just added new
things so this case it was enriched know
so
maybe we did you have um tools like
Forum tools where students could
interact online and discuss problems um
and did you capture that information and
what did you find out from
that yeah this is one slide I showed
about this uh Forum which was on the
Moodle part of it uh in the first pilot
we did in 2012 there wasn't much
interaction but in 2013 we saw we saw a
lot of interaction I think students are
now or the the 18yearold students are
now in a situation where they're used to
interacting with other unknown to them
students online asking things and we saw
this a big change from 2012 2013 lots of
situations like this I'm stuck I don't
get the right answer can you help me I
done this and then another one answering
this is the way you do it oh I I don't
know either so it was an very rich
interaction only with the students I
just want to follow up on that yeah Is
So based on on what you found in the
forums could you identifi pieces within
the lecture videos or some of the
exercises where there was a commonality
let's say in this exercise nobody got it
and we got a lot of traffic here this
means that there was probably the the
information here was not correctly
explained or or adequately expl for this
group did you go back then and say all
right let's modify these videos so it's
it's this iterative process I this is
the advantage of doing online thing that
you can from one year to another improve
the thing we have done it I think we
have to do it more I mean the example I
show I give gave with
the there was a wrong exercise so we
corrected it for the next I we work even
for the same year in this case but we
see the possibility of impr improving
videos the videos that are being run
right now in August 2014 are mostly the
same as the one report except that we
five or six videos which has been
changed on the basis of this experience
and I think this is very important to
take advantage of all the things you
notice in order to improve successively
your your content definitely
yeah um I I uh Ann Taylor from Penn
State University um I just wanted to go
back to the question about the the
learning communities and the
interaction um we've been doing distance
education since
1897 and uh I we have about 14,000
students studying online with Penn State
only not uh they they never come to
campus our average class sizes are
really about 30 35 students online but
we have some that are huge as well and
um I I can just tell you from our
experience you can create just as
incredible a community of Learners in
the online space and solely online no
face-to-face component as you can in a
classroom and it has uh much less to do
with the technology or lack of
Technology as it does the design of the
course and what the faculty member does
to help the students interact with one
another and with the the
instructor and the challenge isn't any
different if you had 30 people in a room
versus having a thousand people in an
auditorium um with regard to how you're
going to facilitate that so it is
absolutely possible to have really
incredible close-knit class uh class
rooms online yeah thank you for for this
uh comment I mean I'm also directing a
master's program on online learning
which is
online people come if they wish at the
end to present their their Master's
project and it's interesting to see them
when they come together oh you look like
this and and there is a very intimate
relationship already and then they see
their faces in real time and real
physical so it's it's a very uh emotion
also filled uh experience yeah
definitely I I totally agree with you um
yeah I can chime in on that so I taught
I taught large scale classes I taught
for edex a 13,000 and a 26,000 scale
class and I I was able to distinguish
the different members of the Class by
their users names they became real
people um but I had a question for you I
was wondering if you had any numbers
about maybe um students who did not open
a single video but did attend the face
tof face part and vice versa students
who did every single video and were
maybe the very good and good students
and didn't come to the face to face I
mean all all who had registered for the
course did the face to face oh every
student came to the face to face okay
but some had more deeper interaction
online or or or or less so and then
another question I was wondering um the
time scale of the online portion and the
phase to phase and the motivation I
think you released all the material at
once online and I was wondering if there
if you thought there might be
Improvement by doing an incremental
steps I mean it's during the month of
August this online parts from the 1 to
the 31st we list everything from the
very
beginning um we see that students see
more the First videos than the last one
uh I I don't believe that we would have
Improvement if we release it it's too
short a time really to to to do a
sequential release of things and in this
way if somebody wants to concentrate
more on Electro we have mechanics and
electromagnetism and physics everything
so if they want to concentrate more on
the electromechanics part even if it's
later they can do it from the very
beginning so they can just pick and
choose what what they need I I I don't
think we would get Improvement if if we
do a partial time
yeah
yes oh okay hi Dan Garcia Berkeley um
we're looking to build a Spock uh based
course to take into the high schools
where there'll always be an instructor
in the room and the moo will just serve
as the kind of learning management
system and online stuff and if they
weren't working home they've got that I
saw that the Spock that you had didn't
have a face-to-face presence it was an
only purely online piece it was first
part was online right but it was but
when you say Spock when you say the word
Spock you meant the online portion is
broken up into different groups and it's
smaller cohorts taking the online class
is that right well maybe I mean like
what what do you mean by SP invented the
word I know the word Spock and maybe
there different understandings of what
spog mean okay so we are using Muk like
technology in a way videos and quizzes
Etc but it's not open it's private okay
and it's not big we don't have thousands
we have hundreds something so this is
why call it small and private and I use
Armando
Fox's acronym I I I would understand
that there are different ways of
implementing Sparks or different
settings maybe you have a different
setting in mind that what I I've done it
yeah my my sense was SP was was small
was in the 30s kind of the classroom
space but I think you're also right that
small is not 100,000 model that but I'm
wondering just for the group whether
they think that the hybrid model may be
the the the model that works best for
most students I just want to see whether
anyone's had experience with the hybrid
model I like to hear from some there
supposed to be
people hi Amy Bennett from the
University of Pennsylvania actually I
had two questions and one of them was
around we did a um High School pilot
with about 10 high schools we did our
calculus Muk and so
the the high schools used it for the
whole Academic Year and they could
self-pace and what we found was what we
were hoping was that they certainly
interacted a little bit on the forums
but they would mostly come to class and
do that and that we were really hoping
is they would interact with all the
schools and we found pretty much zero of
that so I was going to ask you and maybe
this is for discussion is when there is
sort of a flipped setting they seem to
prefer if they can come into class and
that was really small so each school
maybe had I mean they had anywhere from
3 to 20 students
participating that was their preference
versus online so I guess you've had
these rich communities that was their
only choice in a way so when there's a
choice haven't met I mean they fresh
students right and they haven't met the
only possibility to interact was online
and then the only possibility was to
meet face to face so so this was a
complet I think with your questions if
you agree we can go to the second part
of this session I prepared some slides
in order to encourage and to get the
richness of your
experiences pardon
Sherry oh the second okay completely
different question I don't maybe we can
talk about that that piece more but I'm
curious how you're goingon to mark it to
the Bad and the medium students because
you clearly have some data that says
this works if you take it and I was also
going to tie that into the high school
piece do you plan to Market this to
people not quite yet in college to say
if you pass this you have a greater
chance of and maybe it's even gives them
a Advantage as they apply so how you
plan to Market it to the students yeah
we have started to to think about it we
don't have any decision taken I think
the high schools are very important to
to give them chance is also to attract
them to our University by showing them
the good content we have but I mean the
Spanish system is quite different from
American system so there are some U
other uh parameters that uh we don't
know yet what to do exactly but but I
agree that it's important to to help
also the high school students to to come
to the university and to be better
prepared okay if we we have what do we
have half an hour so almost I would like
to take this
opportunity uh to try to get from all
all of
you to identify good blending
experiences I
mean some people say the university is
going to change differently this is a
report from from Australia from two
years ago said in 10 years every
tradition University will be gone and
maybe Google will be doing everything
this is one extreme University will
disappear as we know it some others say
say that okay it has survived 800 years
Keep Calm and Carry On don't do anything
everything will be fine m is just a hype
so but in this between these two
extremes I think we could take advantage
as we have shown in the
previous uh presentation that online
tools are useful even for face-to-face
students no and I think we need models
to follow that blend this traditional
with online um technology no and I have
presented just one possible model no
this this uh leveling approach first
online and then face to face for
sure the flip classroom is another
model rather than doing it like this
first uh lecturing and then homework we
capture we record the lectures and then
do the flipping so that uh you can view
the recordings at home and free time for
the professor to be guiding your
side okay I think we need more of these
models we need more examples and maybe
we can advance here one step and hearing
from you what you are useful ways of
blending online traditional and maybe we
try to identify some models give them
names and then have others uh this as an
inspiration for for using them in the in
their particular settings no uh
so let me go yeah bit further so the
problem statement is we want to hear
about your blend ination experiences
then we want to C cize them and we will
try to identify useful models and we
trying I think I propose to use a
brainstorming technique and this
means that we have distributed some
small
papers there are some pens which has
been also distributed for those who
don't have and maybe you can write down
your
favorite Blended
experience then you you can explain it
here then we'll put them here on the
black but then we try to categorize them
and to see whether we can find good
models is this a good
proposal yeah okay
Sherry is also helping me she's from
adex thank you very much for helping us
so if you agree just write down your
favorite Blended experience come up to
the mic or or where's the mic pass it
around and when then we'll put them here
and we'll try to make some categories to
see whether we can
all learn from the different experiences
okay I'm good how are you good so I'm
Kevin Lynch from Colgate University so
we're doing a blended we actually have
two courses now um we're calling it
Fusion because we don't know else to
call
but we have the students on campus in
class for credit participating in a Muk
that's also offered for alumni parents
and friends and so in the one course
it's um I'll talk more about it tomorrow
Advent of the atomic bomb it's to get
that perspective from an older
generation to our current students about
what was happening with the decision and
leading up to the atomic bomb and the
aftermath the other course is a living
writers online where we have 10
International authors come to campus we
highlight four of those in our moo and
again the in class students interact
with parents alumni and friends from
around the globe with different
perspectives on that and there's
different activities so I don't know
what you call that but we've gotten
really really good feedback and um one
course is just about to launch the other
course we actually ran in the spring and
we did see a a huge uptick in student
engagement which was actually surprising
so this is a combination of a moo and a
Spock so you enrich a Spock with a moo
and well it's it's it's not a spar
because it's it's a inclass it's a
traditional class traditional class
where they participate in a moo with
outside folks that are taking a subset
of the course okay so maybe write one
keyword it's a traditional plus Muk
together yeah yeah yeah very good very
good um Adam vardell Welsley College uh
this past year I taught Welsley First
moo but I taught it in conjunction with
an on-campus seminar course that had 15
students and one of my goals was to try
to Leverage The advantageous properties
of the small seminar style classroom to
improve the moo experience while also
leveraging the properties of the the
massiveness of the moo to improve the in
on campus Rick and mortar seminar
classroom so one of the goals for that
is well what do we like about our wisy
college classes we like that they're
directed class sessions but ones where
you're not certain necessarily entirely
what direction it's going to go the kind
of spontaneity of an in-class discussion
with engaged Learners that ideally you
want to use that as a model for the kind
of discussion fors you want to develop
online so we videotaped select class
sessions where we knew we'd have
directed discussions but without a clear
sense of what direction those were going
to go and use those then as video models
actually to feed discussion forums in
the actual Muk itself and those
discussion forms were actually very
successful um it took a lot of work
because editing a 70-minute class down
into something that's maybe 15 or 20
minutes that's useful that online
Learners will follow is hard it requires
a lot of effort at the same time the
class was about human evolution so
largely focused on issues of human
variation you can only sample so much
variation out of a class of 15 students
um but a class of 15,000 students
there's possible to see a lot more of
what real variation looks like so trying
to sample that variation of the actual
massiveness of the online class
something I could never do in my
oncampus seminar and bring that as
pedagogical material into my on campus
classroom um and that was successful
though there you run into challenges
related to privacy issues and exactly
how you're managing these data and what
kind of data you're really producing um
but trying to take advantage of the
advantages of a small classroom to
improve the the big massive classroom
and doing the opposite as well trying to
take advantage of the properties of
massiveness to improve the small
oncampus learning experience so this is
somehow related to to yours but it's bit
different different because you also
record the traditional classes and feed
them into the moo no so it's record
select elements out of the individual
class so it's it's similar but with some
nuances some differences very
interesting very
good uh so um just to to quickly get
back to what you had been asking before
um I'm my background is an instructional
designer I'm an administrator now but
that's my 20 years of experience um
Blended best but it's not possible for
everyone so the 14 th000 students that I
was saying we have online they can't
come to our campuses so um we are
thrilled that we can help them study and
learn successfully online but yeah the
ideal would be the Blended so the
example I wanted to share that I think
is cool um a faculty member just started
working with my Institute to develop a
sustainability course there where he
uses Jamaica as the microcosm uh to
study sustainability it's an island you
know you you got a lot of control there
and in the past it was a face-to-face
class where he took about 15 students in
the culmination of the class to Jamaica
for two weeks so they studied face Toof
face throughout the semester and then at
the end of the semester together they
went to Jamaica and put into practice
everything they'd been learning what
we're doing now with him is putting that
course
online so that everything but that
Jamaica experience is now going to be
online and instead of 15 students we
hope to have a 100 students 15 of them
will go to Jamaica at the end of the
semester the other 85 who will be our
distance Learners all over the world
will continue to work like this with
them using Skype using discussion forums
using and and being as much a part of
that experience feeding them data
researching things things you know going
back and forth as as we can humanly you
know put into that course so that Those
Distant students get as much out of that
final two weeks as the on ground
students do and I thought that was a
really cool way to make the best of both
worlds and to uh integrate students who
are not physically able to be physically
together how would
you summarize this into a headline a new
category because this is additional
thing and people traveling so this is
not traditional class it's people
traveling and acting as of them yeah
part of them acting as delegates for the
others is repor someone else come I'm
bad at titles someone come up with a
good we'll use it
uhuh okay hi I'm Carrie from canvas
Network um I support a lot of uh faculty
at different schools and different
institutions of every size all over the
world and building their different mukes
and uh one of the great things is to see
bringing a public audience into the
classroom uh I coached a faculty member
who wanted to do a a course on popular
music and and to have that global
perspective because the the semantics
just understanding what the songs are
about just to bring in that global
perspective is fascinating um for the
thank you very much that's a great segue
we couldn't plan that any better
thinking about Project based learning
thinking about distance Learners who
want to participate fully but they can't
be present right now we're working um
with suffk University doing a course on
the history of
Boston now not everybody can come to
Boston however we can craft activities
and do discussion prompts that says go
to your community we're going to learn
about the you know the history here in
Boston now go to your community and find
a landmark find a historical figure find
a monument find a statue that tells a
similar story and tell less about your
culture so it really opens up Global
Learning and I can throw at a term it's
not my term but this this liberated
structure we can have the structure of a
course but we can liberate it Tear Down
the Walls let people have some freedom
and some control about how they're
interpreting they're learning how they
can do some sense making of their own
and empower the students term um I can
contribute is is crowd
commissioning U which is
right commissioning so you you
commission the people to do something
and take advantage and and bring it back
to the to the class so it's I mean crowd
commissioning would be I think would fit
into what you Crow commissioning do you
like that do you agree
that yes so um as I mentioned before the
model we're going to try to do is is the
Spock vision is to have high school
teachers all feel ownership so one of
the important things we're working with
a lot of high school teachers the last
three or four years is to not have it
feel like we we're the only ones who
know anything CU we live in the Ivory
Tower and you just follow our moo and
and that that's an issue so what we're
trying to do in the Spock model is to
have the online resource we we've
marketed as the greatest ebook ever and
you as a high school teacher can make a
decision what modules you like and what
modules you don't like and so it's being
able to kind of customize it in that
model so a model the high school teacher
has control over the whole thing in
theory they have the analytics they have
their their 10 students 20 students and
they see they can see the charts the
beautiful KH Academy charts again edex
has to give us some that's a challenge
but we're going to get some those Con
Academy charts as well the real question
I think is interesting is where are the
borders you can imagine uh aquariums and
here the sharks are swimming over here
and this might be some high futin school
and they're all brilliant kids and
they're over here and so here's another
group of challenge students and here's
some other and so you have have them all
in there they're all inheriting the
course from you and the Spock model they
all kind of make a copy of the course
and they have it and they can decide to
throw away module three and for their
students they never see module three
they just see one two 2 four and five it
seems seamless to them you know the
check boxes all just work and this group
likes all of them this one this group
wants to this one teacher wants to add a
module that's all fine it's all
wonderful the question I have for you is
where should you let the fish play you
know when do you raise up the borders
between these courses and let the
students work together one of the
comments I think Amy had was the
students don't and the calculus didn't
talk together right so what are the
things that can be gained by allowing
them to talk together what are the
things that be gained by realizing that
you're part of a larger global community
of students all learning the same course
maybe at different rates and and because
of the different rates people are asking
questions about week seven versus week
one because that's where we are because
we're a different time just what are the
benefits of having them play together I
think I'm still challenged with because
I as of now I just keep them all in
separate put pins just let them talk
within their own group and that's all
you have but they're all in a high
school so why do they need to talk
together online because they already
talk to each other all the time so was a
little bit of like what are the benefits
of Mo within the group and what are the
benefits of putting them all in the same
pool have several I think at the at the
back he he
was um at the back is also later it
would yeah well I just want to say one
of the benefits of letting them all play
together especially on a large scale
class is that you can have less staff
you know I was teaching this 26,000
student person I was the instructor and
I had one ta we tapped the community and
had you know 10 Community Tas they were
helping the students students were
helping each other there were student
run contests that they were organizing
on their own and so that's the big
benefit you know that's the benefit of
letting them play and you know it would
tapen to the the good and the very good
students how to improve them because now
they're helping the bad
students
yeah hi I have a really interesting use
case of uh combining uh M large scale
Global open course with a Spock so we're
working with um Professor Jeffrey Sachs
at Columbia University and he's got this
great mil on sustainability and 26
universities worldwide want to inherit
that material and teach it in a
classroom environment but to enhance the
experience of the students so in each
classroom there's only like 30 students
in each University and a lot of
sustainability problems may be existing
somewhere else in the field so we've
created two instances of open adex so my
company um offers an open adex private
instances and so we've created two
instance one is a Muk open Global course
where we expect 100,000 students
worldwide who's going to enroll we are
running currently we running a test M uh
and it'll start uh next month and then
there 26 universities uh instructors are
going to take we creating a private
instance for these 26 universities one
for all of them one instance for 26
unties but these are all classroom where
each of the 26 instructors and the T are
going to take part of that material from
jeffre saxs mhm and they're going to run
a four credit paid on campus course now
where this two groups intersect is
really in Project based learning because
you know sustainability could be a very
dry topic unless you actually are faced
with real world problem like you know
what is the water problem in in Africa
or you know how do you put a sewer line
in in India mhm so this classroom
students are going to really benefit
from this 100,000 people globally
because those people are some of them
are practitioners they are not a student
in the classroom uh they might be
working in governments and they might be
actually putting up you know water lines
somewhere so the way the those two
communities are going to intersect is in
two ways one is in projects so when
projects are given this communities are
going to be any encouraged to partner
with people outside the classroom M so
they can actually find people in the
group so we've created collaboration
applications on the top of open addex
where the discussion forums can
intersect where although these two
instances are separate one is open and
free and uh for anyone in the world to
join another instance is just for this
single sign on through the institution
mhm there is a forum area where both
those communities can talk to each other
and in that Forum in this discussion
forum the instructors can go and put a
project there and people can form their
own groups so although it looks like a
very large community of 100,000 people
the the people this the communities can
intersect between Global and local in
groups of as little as just five people
and they work on a specific project and
then they post their assignment and then
there is peer grading you know using the
adex capability and then there is some
uh peer voting and grading system inside
the discussion forum where U you know it
encourages them to participate and do
that group collaboration and then to
Amy's point about um you know how do you
get them to really participate and and
in the discussion forum the grading for
those 26 University students because
it's a four credit course part of that
grading you know 20% of the grading is
based on their participation in the
discussion forum so they are encouraged
to reach out to people outside the
classroom outside the people those 20
people in the room because other 20
people are there all in that country in
that room you know they don't have
they're not going to bring as much
diverse perspective as people outside
the world so that is you know enabling
them to really participate and seek
other people form the groups create that
collaboration work on that uh project
post it and then help other people and
so this is really great example of open
adex because it allows you to do that
because you know we've grabbed the open
source open adex instruments we can
create this multiple instances we can
merge these two instances we can create
additional collaborative applications on
the top of of it and then make this kind
of M and Spark all coming together with
the projects and I think the project
very the same EXA course and it is multi
University and also engaging anybody in
the world who wants to be part of that
experience give it the name yeah I'm
struggling actually this is so fantastic
this such a great session because you
know we've been like thinking about what
is this name where Muk marries with
Spock and like different ways to marry
them yeah sorry so Project based Muk
Spock come
something like this yeah I think this is
one more flavor potentially I mean we
might all be saying sort of the same
thing I think there's these little
variations yeah little variations but
those are what's key so this might be
another use case we did two design
courses one is in it's actually fifth
run it's a moo and the thing about
design is that not only is it Project
based but it's kind of the journey that
matters so what you do identify the need
you come up with Solutions you test them
Etc so it's this process and you have to
show this process and actually in a moo
with peer grading it's hard to do that
because you don't have the same five
people looking at each time so we had to
find a way where people could look at
the journey if you will so they knew the
work you were doing so um one thing
about Project based learning is you get
to see things along the way and
typically in class students would get
critiqued or show that to their
instructor but it's kind of a private
somewhat private process now you're sort
of putting it out there and what that
does is it makes all the future students
to come see what the where the bar is
and see what's possible with different
types of projects so back to this we did
a designing cities course and our
professors had Philadelphia to work with
so students would go out into a
community in Philadelphia which offers a
lot of Rich opportunity but it was
contained Philadelphia so when we did
the Muk on designing cities we had
students from around around the world in
their own cities and communities taking
a problem and presenting a solution and
now those professors have thousands of
examples from other cities to kind of
bring back into the classroom so again
it's this kind of hybrid um but I think
the idea of when you push the boundaries
and you can select from a pool it just
raises
everybody's mhh you know quality of what
they maybe the first phase of the MS was
C Iz to everybody and now it's it's
coming back no to taking advantage of
this connection in order to enrich
everybody but the other way around yeah
that's good
TC yeah I'm TC pong from the Hong Kong
University of Science and Technology I
just want to share with you uh one uh
one model that we are calling at the the
extended flip
model model U what uh we are doing is on
a mook called science of gastronomy
science of cooking
uh we have offered the cost twice uh
that attracted over 100,000 students uh
What uh we have done in the spraying
semester is that we allow our students
to take the book during the semester and
then after the book we have given that
our our own student we have around 40
students sign up for this book and then
during the summer they actually are
taking the course on campus and then at
the end they'll earn a credit for it so
um they really benefit from the diverse
opinion from the discussion forum
because there are Chef who have who had
40 years of experience they talk about
vegetarian cocing Western cocaine and
Chinese COC now they are bringing back
uh the idea uh in class when they
actually try to uh do the cooking uh but
so um on the M you cannot really uh do
the cooking as a group but now they can
yeah do it on campus uh what we are
trying to do now is to uh use that as a
way to expand the student Exchange
program uh so that because um for this
kind of extended book the student would
can finish the course in just a few
weeks rather than the entire semester so
um we are now working with some Partners
in Asia uh so after they have taken the
book during the summer uh they can come
to our campus or our students can go to
their campus to finish the course and
earn credit for it so I think this is a
a way that not only that we can take
care of take advantage of the book to do
that SP we also look at this as a
platform for inter institutional
collaboration very good so it's the moo
to prepare for the real experience and
then you do it with other universities
as well very
good okay we are almost 12 maybe we take
two more and then we close it you and
and you I'll try to be brief um one of
the challenges with Blended learning and
all these Blended environments is how do
you aggregate the information so you
actually understand what the
participation of the students are um and
I guess one of the challenges with
Blended learning is how do you aggregate
the information how do you access the
information that your students were
accessing from Facebook because all that
is private data um how do you access
information from KH Academy they might
have apis but they don't you don't get
all the information that you want um and
how do you bring all that together to
actually get the clear picture of what
is going on in a blended course because
you don't know what communities are
forming and and how people are really
exchanging information we understand
it's a really good model and it's a good
pedagogical model but we don't really
have the the the tools to understand the
analytics behind why it is a good model
so I would encourage to sort of figure
ways of bringing the technology that can
a aggregate all this information
together very
good so I wanted to talk about uh a
Spock I think it was a Spock that I gave
um but I'm an amateur at this so take it
with a you know it's it's nowhere near
the scale of some of the institutional
models being done here but I thought I'd
bring it up and it's um a course where
we teach um algorithm development to
engineering students but I do it in
China where students are learning are
using English as their second language
and where they're going to be exposed
for the very first time to the teaching
methods that typically I use that are
typical of MIT and universities here in
the US versus the uh more conventional
teaching methods in China and after
teaching it one year in person there and
understanding the students a lot better
it was very modest group of students I
had maybe 30 um I returned and I taught
what I called a sandwich course and my
sandwich course was um oriented to make
sure that I could make a personal
connection to the students um so what I
did as the first part of the sandwich
was I went to China and I taught them in
person for one week in a very intensive
experience where I got to know them and
we got to review preview the course
material and the course goals then I
went back to MIT and for nine weeks I
offered the material online through edx
the students were also working with a
Moodle that had been customized much
like your Moodle um for them which had a
both an English and a Chinese interface
and then I returned because what we did
online was we constructed modules that
had outcomes that you could then put
together in the final week as projects
and I worked with a second instructor
and we did a Project based portion of
the course to review the concepts and
pull everything together I just wanted
to mention that it wasn't necessarily a
success it had a lot of challenges and I
only by teaching it the first time did I
know those as opposed to solve them um
one was that the students communicated
on QQ which is a Chinese chat facility
and they completely stayed off our
social forums uh we tried to entice them
with all sorts of ways it actually took
a lot of work to tell the Tas that they
should bring them try and bring them
back to the um online forums we had and
the second thing is that the students
had to deal with the technology being
less than perfect you know the videos
took a long time to download the open
edex servers we were running in China
were a little bit less than
underprovision um so they were grouping
together to look at the material
sometimes but we couldn't capture that
in our
analytics so sh we call this the
sandwich model maybe right and so there
we were sitting here in the US for nine
weeks with them far away and our Bridge
was the teaching assistants right we had
met those teaching assistants we had
made them brought them along to be
invested in the outcomes of the course
and they were our connection but that's
a very tenuous connection when you're
far away so anything that would help our
teaching assistants provide that link
while you're far away in distance
learning all those you know and I I know
other people it's not just a
technological search solution I'm
looking for I'm looking for what was
mentioned earlier which is that it's
course design that's going to make the
difference here and so I'm very
interested in hearing those ideas about
how course design in that situation we
called a sandwich because I went there
we had the Muk in the middle and then we
uh went back so it was a sandwich course
okay it's time to finish unfortunately
because the conversation was very rich I
wanted to categorize this we don't have
any time maybe Shar and I we can try
to yeah maybe we can write something to
summarize it and and then post it
somehow so thank you very much everybody
for your contributions
very
interesting